hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and today we're going to
talk about the apt t blood tests and as
always whenever you get done watching
this youtube video you can access the
free quiz that will test you on this
content so let's get started what is an
apt T well this is a blood test used to
assess how fast the blood clots and apt
T stands for activated partial
thromboplastin time and how we collect
this test is we stick a patient's vein
we remove some blood put it in a special
tube and send it to the lab who will run
this test now this test is helpful in
determining if maybe a patient has a
bleeding disorder because it's going to
look at specific clotting factors within
this coagulation cascade also this test
is helpful for monitoring a patient who
is on heparin and we talked about this
in depth in our pharmacology review over
heparin but again to review heparin is
an indirect thrombin inhibitor and why
did their own Ben do again thrombin
helps play a huge role in that claudine
process by turning fibrinogen into
fibrin so once we get fibrin on board
that helps really give our clot form
because it's mesh like strands that
allow substances to stick to it we get a
clot to help treat whatever is going on
usually excessive bleeding
so heparin what it does is it is going
to enhance the activity of a naturally
occurring substance in our body called
antithrombin 3 and what this is going to
do is this going to prevent the
activation of thrombin so we won't be
able to have fibrinogen turn into fibrin
so we're gonna prolong how long it takes
for this patient to form a clot so we're
gonna prolong this really coagulation
cascade and sometimes if they're really
wanting to investigate what's going on
with this patient do they have a
bleeding disorder they're also probably
going to order a PT I in our level as
well and we talked about that in the
previous video so let's talk about this
coagulation cascade because it's gonna
help us understand what we're actually
looking at in our patient when we're
ordering an a PTT
so this process is started let's say
whenever a patient has maybe some type
of external injury that's going to
deplete their vascular system of blood
or they have some inside injury within
that vascular system that's causing some
type of issue and we need a cloth there
to prevent from depleting that vascular
system of blood because if we lose all
of our blood and our body for dead we
don't have anything to profuse our
organs and body and we're not going to
survive so the coagulation cascade is
made up of three pathways we have the
intrinsic pathway the extrinsic pathway
and the common pathway and these two
pathways intrinsic and extrinsic meet
together at this common pathway to
actually create a clot and certain
clotting factors depending on the
pathway will be activated in a certain
sequence so we get clot formation and if
a PTT is going to check the intrinsic
pathway now the intrinsic pathway is
activated when we have internal damage
or injury within that vascular system
the extrinsic pathway it's activated
when we have external injury that's
going to deplete our vascular system of
blood loss now whenever we talked about
the pt/inr that was what that blood test
was checking that extrinsic and those
associated clotting factors with
intrinsic this is what the PAP TT is
checking so the intrinsic pathway deals
with clotting factor 12 11 9 and 8 then
it's also going to be looking at the
common pathway so really how the
intrinsic pathway and the common pathway
are working together and when we're
talking about the common pathway we're
talking about factor 1 2 5 and 10 now
let's take what we have learned about
the AP TT and apply to what we need to
know as the nurse and some things we
need to know are the normal ranges and
how that applies to heparin therapy
so the a PTT is measured in seconds and
you may be wondering what's the
difference between an a PTT versus a PTT
well they measure the same thing they're
looking at the intrinsic and the common
pathways and how they're working
together
but the a PTT has an activator agent
that is used in it that helps speed up
the clotting time so that's why we call
it an activated partial thromboplastin
time hence why this doesn't have an A in
front of it so because of that it's
going to give us a more of a narrow
range and these ranges vary depending on
the lab generally it's about 30 to 40
seconds as your normal range but let's
say your patients on heparin you want
them a little bit higher than that right
because we want to prolong a clot
forming so with heparin therapy you want
to commit this number to memory you want
them about one and a half to two and a
half times the normal range for them to
be therapeutic and for a PTT the range
is about 60 to 70 seconds okay so that
wraps up this review over the aPTT blood
test and don't forget to access the free
quiz that will test you on this content